after loki episode 4 the nexus event
ended with a shocking cliffhanger the
way for episode 5 was excruciating but
now the latest installment journey into
mystery has arrived and with it some big
questions
here's the ending of loki episode 5
explained
it's established very quickly thanks to
a forced confession from judge renslayer
to sylvie that the tva's pruning batons
don't actually kill variants instead
they transport them to a place in time
called the void where they can be
vaporized by a malevolent smoky force
called goliath
the void's existence is obviously a
highly classified tba secret which is
why loki didn't learn about it when he
was asking for files from the clerk back
in episode 2.
in marvel comics goliath is closely tied
to a notorious time traveling villain
who many fans are expecting to see very
soon in ant-man and the wasp quantomania
kang the conqueror
and he's reportedly being played by
lovecraft country star jonathan magers
the big smokey beast had his own
temporal empire when he was originally
introduced back in 1993's avengers
determinatrix objective number one
but kang constructed a time barrier to
keep the villain out of his own domain
called chronopolis
that doesn't sound too dissimilar to
what the tva has done with eliath and
loki trapping the entity in the void so
they can use him to wipe out pesky
variants and other things that don't
belong in the sacred timeline
the bulk of the episode follows our main
loki chatting with the other variants
and discovering what makes him so
different from himself
all while trying to find a way to defeat
goliath and figure out who's really
behind the tva
the episode doesn't rush through things
giving this god squad plenty of time to
bounce off one another all while
expanding the mythology and development
of everyone's favorite god of mischief
classic loki explains how he lived past
the events of avengers infinity war
he reveals that he conjured an illusion
of himself so exacting that he fooled
thanos into thinking that decoy was real
and that he killed loki from there
classic loki went into hiding as
inanimate debris
cowardly and smart yes that's classic
loki alright
but not only is it an insightful
anecdote as to what loki's are capable
of when they put their mind to it
it's also a clue as to how the vibrantly
dressed character will have an impact in
the final fight against elia
it all ends in a big scuffle when a
variant will call president loki shows
up with an army of other variant loki's
from across the void's wasteland
however they all start betraying each
other because that's just what loki's do
isn't it at this point it looks like the
small appearance from president loki
might debunk a few of those theories
suggesting that he's the one behind the
tva
it's still not impossible but it's
highly unlikely
they just couldn't stay apart for too
long could they silvi follows loki to
the void after renslayer reveals that
the void is a place at the end of the
timeline
that means it's out of harm's way and
can't affect past events
sylvie's self-pruning shows that the
variant clearly cares as deeply for the
main loki as he cares for her her main
motivation is finding out who's really
behind the tva
but she's just not very good at
expressing her emotions
this is something that comes across very
clearly in a touching moment leading up
to the final battle
while kid classic and gator loki shelter
in a hollowed-out building with mobius
loki and sylvie huddled together in a
conjured blanket while they try to
untangle the romantic mess they created
for themselves
it's clearly the first time sylvie has
ever let herself be vulnerable with
anyone so it's quite fitting that she's
opening up to an alternate version of
herself
but she even struggles to connect with
loki i don't have
friends
i don't have anyone
finally loki gets his own redemption arc
because he promises not to betray sylvie
he hugs mobius and calls him a friend
before the tva agent heads
back to work to burn it down loki and
silvi head off to face a liat themselves
while the rest of the god squad decides
to stay in the void
after all this is their home now
thankfully sylvie vetoes loki's simple
plan of trying to stab a smoke monster
and goes with her idea of enchanting the
creature and revealing where and who the
person behind the tba is
however just because she's been
nefariously murderous up to this point
doesn't mean she can't inspire loki to
have a little faith in himself
he unlocks his own enchanting abilities
just in the nick of time on the
battlefield with a little
encouragement from sylvie thankfully
classic loki decides to give his life
glorious purpose by creating a fake
asgard to distract elia
it's a brilliant moment to witness
especially for an older bitter version
of the character to finally feel like
he's doing something positive in the
timeline rather than constantly being a
villain
his trickery succeeds but at the cost of
his life however classic loki points out
earlier on that he cheated death by
conjuring a fake version of himself
during the confrontation with thanos so
who knows
once eliath is enchanted the smoke
clears to show a bizarre castle or manor
in the middle of a swirling cosmic
background
with all the kang the conqueror
connections to eliyah is it possible
that this is chronopolis
goliath clearly couldn't get inside it
in the comics chronopolis lies on the
outskirts of limbo and contains time
points to places under kang's control
will we see jonathan majors as kang next
week in the loki finale
only time will tell check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one